I think it is a terrifying thought for anyone who spends their life learning, honestly.
Oh, absolutely.
Just the idea that you could dedicate decades to gathering facts and mastering all these complex arguments, building this huge intellect, only to find out that the sheer volume of your learning is exactly the thing that ruins you.
Yeah, it is a devastating reality to confront.
It really is.
Yeah.
And we are looking directly at you, the listener, as we open the final pages of the text called O Beloved Son.
This is just such a deeply historical, urgent correspondence.
It is a master writing back to his student.
And this student had desperately asked for a functional path, not just more theory.
Right.
He wanted something he could actually apply.
Exactly.
So for this deep dive, our mission is to examine the master's ultimate framework.
At the very end of his letter, he distills decades of spiritual and intellectual observation, and he hands the disciple 8 distinct contours.
Yeah, the final instructions.
Yes.
He explicitly outlines 4 habits that the seeker must categorically refuse and four quiet habits that must be actively taken up.
And the purpose of this framework is singular, so that his hard-earned knowledge does not turn against him on the day of judgment.
Of these eight admonitions, there are four things you must do and four things you must not do so that your knowledge does not turn against you on the day of judgment.
That single sentence, I mean, it establishes an incredibly high stakes reality.
It does.
We spend decades sitting in classrooms, reading texts, absorbing information.
We operate under this assumption that knowing the truth is the exact same thing as being transformed by it.
Which is a massive illusion.
It is, and the master is stripping that illusion away completely.
He is telling the disciple that having the right information or being able to articulate the correct theological points decides absolutely nothing about his ultimate fate.
Nothing at all.
Knowledge is entirely inert until it takes physical and psychological form in our actions.
What that knowledge becomes when it is translated into conduct is literally.
The only one.
And the master, Gaz A.H.
Lee, structures these final instructions in a way that reveals just a deep understanding of human psychology.
He begins with the four prohibitions, the things the disciple must completely refrain from.
And what is so unsettling about these four traps
is that they do not look like traps.
No, not at all.
They are not outward crimes.
They are subtle, they are intellectual, and they are highly respected within religious circles.
That is the danger.
A person slides into them precisely because the religious surface of the act looks completely intact.
I mean, if a trap looks like a trap, you walk around it.
Exactly.
But if a trap looks like a noble pursuit of truth, you walk right into it, completely convinced of your own righteousness.
You do.
So let us start with the first admonition, because it is bracing and it's
absolute sweep.
He instructs the disciple to categorically refuse the habit of religious debate.
Completely refuse it.
He tells him to avoid, as far as possible, engaging in disputes with anyone, on any matter, any matter at all.
Not just trivial things, everything.
I have to admit, my immediate reaction to that sweeping prohibition is to push back.
Oh, for sure.
I mean, if a person possesses knowledge and they see someone spreading falsehood or misunderstanding, isn't there a moral obligation to step in and defend the truth?
That is what the ego wants you to think.
Well, yeah.
How can walking away from an argument be the righteous choice
when the truth is under attack.
It feels like an abdication of duty.
It does.
The ego desperately wants to frame it as this noble defense of the sacred, but the master is looking past that surface excuse.
He is pointing directly to the hidden internal harms that these disputes generate.
The psychological damage.
Exactly.
He's stating that the psychological damage inflicted upon your own soul during a debate far outweighs any theoretical benefit of winning the argument.
He actually lists the harvest of this habit, doesn't he?
Does.
He lists the observable harvest that the habit of disputation produces, and it is a catastrophic list for the soul.
He says it produces ostentation, jealousy, arrogance, resentment, enmity, pride, and egotism.
Those are the exact traits that ruin the heart.
Completely ruin it.
But I really want to understand the mechanism here.
Why does arguing about a point of objective truth inherently produce arrogance or resentment?
What is actually happening inside the person?
Well, the profound psychological insight the master offers is that the human soul is just an unreliable narrator of its own motives.
Unreliable how?
In the heat of an argument, when your blood is rushing and another person is publicly contradicting your intellect, the soul cannot distinguish between defending the objective truth and defending its own fragile ego.
They blend together.
They do.
You think you are fighting for the purity of the doctrine, but you are actually just fighting to assert your own supremacy.
You are fighting not to be humiliated.
I mean, that makes perfect sense.
The soul wraps its desire for dominance in the noble cloak of defending the faith.
Exactly.
When someone contradicts a point I have made, the immediate physical sensation is defensive.
It is a sting.
I want to prove them wrong.
Not just so the truth is known, but so that I am recognized as the one who knew it.
And that is the ostentation he warns about.
When you debate, you are performing.
You are on stage.
You want the opponent and any onlookers to recognize how articulate, clever, and well-read you are.
The performance becomes entirely detached from the sincere desire to serve the creator.
And the outcomes are lose-lose for the soul.
They really are.
If your opponent makes a better point, it breeds resentment and jealousy.
If you
To make a better point, it breeds arrogance and pride.
The ego feeds regardless of the outcome, while the heart starves.
That is a terrifying bind to be in.
But the master does not say debate is universally forbidden in every conceivable instance, does he?
No, he does provide an exception.
A sort of internal diagnostic test.
Yes, but the bar to clear is incredibly high.
He tells the disciple that if an argument arises and your genuine singular desire is simply for the truth to prevail, then your intention might be sound.
Might be sound.
Right.
However, knowing how deceptive the ego is, you cannot simply declare to yourself that your intention is pure.
You have to rigorously test that intention against two specific inward signs.
Let us break down those two signs, because they seem designed to completely short circuit the ego.
What is the first sign?
The first sign is total absolute indifference to whose mouth the truth comes from.
Total indifference.
Whether the truth ultimately emerges from your own tongue or from the tongue of your opponent, it must make absolutely no difference to your emotional state.
You must be equally satisfied in either case.
I want to linger on that because achieving that state requires a massive dismantling of the self.
It really does.
If I am in a tense discussion,
and the other person suddenly articulates the perfect resolving point, my initial reaction is almost never pure joy.
No, rarely.
It is usually a very quiet internal frustration that I didn't think of at first.
I feel defeated even if the issue is resolved.
And the master is saying that if you feel even a fraction of that sting, your intention was corrupt from the start.
That is a heavy standard.
If you feel that sting, you are defending yourself.
You are not defending the truth.
If you were truly a servant of the truth, you would rejoice that the truth arrived, regardless of which vessel carried it.
Because the ego demands to be the hero of the story.
Yes, but the sincere heart just wants the story to end with the truth.
That alone probably disqualifies 99% of the debates we engage in.
Easily.
What is the second sign?
The second sign is that you actively consider it preferable to discuss the matter in private, away from any audience or spectators.
A preference for isolation.
Why is the absence of an audience so critical?
Because spectators are the absolute fuel for ostentation.
They invite performance.
Exactly.
When others are watching, the scakes of the argument shift from what is right to who looks better.
If you truly solely care about resolving A misunderstanding with another human being, you do not need anyone else in the room.
You just need the other person.
Right.
If you find yourself wanting others to hear the debate, wanting them to witness your cleverness or see you dismantle the other person's logic, then your heart has already abandoned the truth.
It is busy building a monument to itself.
Beautifully put.
And both of these signs, the indifference to the source of truth and the preference for privacy are entirely inward.
Only you
You and your creator know if you possess them.
This framework completely changes how a person of knowledge should interact with questions and challenges.
It demands a level of self-interrogation that is exhausting but clearly necessary.
It is necessary for survival.
And this leads directly into a fascinating aside the master provides.
He recognizes that a scholar is going to face questions.
Yeah, it is inevitable.
So he offers a practical typology for handling questioners using this extended analogy of a physician and a patient.
It is a vital framework.
Dealing with questions that originate from a corrupt place is one of the most draining aspects of a life dedicated to study.
So what is the analogy?
The master establishes that asking questions about complex religious and spiritual matters is like describing the invisible diseases of the heart to a physician.
The ignorant questioners are the patients.
the scholars are the physicians of the heart.
But he makes a very sharp distinction about the qualifications of the physician too.
He doesn't just assume anyone who has read a book can cure these diseases.
He is very strict about this.
He notes that imperfect scholars, those who have gathered facts but have not purified their own intentions, are utterly incapable of curing these deep spiritual diseases.
They cannot heal what they suffer from themselves.
Exactly.
Only A perfected scholar can cure them.
More
Actually, only a perfected scholar has the diagnostic vision to identify the root causes of the disease.
He warns that if a disease worsens because its true causes cannot be identified, the patient must seek a more expert physician.
A true physician of the heart knows exactly which ailments are curable and which are terminal.
And expending effort trying to cure an incurable disease is, in his words, nothing but a waste of time.
A complete waste.
So he breaks down these patients, these various types of questioners into four specific categories.
And he makes the startling claim that only one of them is actually worth the medicine.
Yes, only one.
Let us examine the incurable cases first.
Who is the first patient?
The first patient is the jealous one.
The jealous one.
This is the questioner who asks not to learn, but out of hidden jealousy or who raises endless objections purely from envy.
And what is the master's diagnosis here?
It is uncompromising.
He states that jealousy is a lethal, chronic disease that has no cure.
Wait, no cure at all.
That is a definitive verdict to render on another human being.
It is.
Why is jealousy categorized as entirely incurable by the scholar?
Because the nature of jealousy makes the very act of teaching counterproductive.
How so?
It is a condition that consumes the reality of the afflicted person.
The master explains to the disciple that whatever answer you give to the jealous one, no matter how profoundly sound, articulate, or compassionate it is,
That person will only regard you as an enemy.
Because they don't want an answer.
Right.
The fire of their envy will only burn more fiercely with every true and beautiful word you speak.
That is tragic.
Because the truth and eloquence of your words only serve to highlight the exact qualities they feel they lack.
Precisely.
By answering them brilliantly, you are actually worsening their disease.
Your excellence is the source of their pain.
He cites wisdom stating that every kind of animosity has the potential to be remedied except the animosity that is born of jealousy.
It cannot be negotiated with.
It cannot.
Therefore, he instructs the disciple to simply turn away.
Leave the jealous person to remain afflicted with their disease.
Walk away.
Yes.
There is absolutely no intellectual answer you can provide that will help them because their problem is not intellectual.
It is a profound spiritual resentment.
Your engagement only feeds their sickness.
Turning away from someone who is actively objecting to your work takes an immense amount of discipline.
The natural instinct is to defend yourself, to prove them wrong.
But recognizing that their malice is a symptom of an incurable disease and just letting it go requires real spiritual maturity.
It is the only safe response.
Then we move to the second category of patient.
The second patient is the foolish one.
This is the questioner whose disease arises from a profound lack of intelligence and foolishness.
And the master uses an extraordinary reference here involving Jesus, peace be upon him.
How does he frame this?
He notes that Jesus, peace be upon him, stated that while he was, by the absolute permission of God, capable of restoring the dead to life, he was utterly incapable of curing the fool and the ignorant.
To have the miraculous capacity to raise the dead, but to find foolishness an insurmountable barrier.
It really highlights the absolute stubbornness of this condition.
How exactly does the master define this particular brand of foolishness?
It cannot just be a lack of basic education.
No, it is a very specific arrogance.
ignorance.
He defines the fool as someone who has spent only a brief, superficial fraction of time acquiring knowledge.
Just scratch the surface.
Exactly.
They have barely touched intellectual and transmitted religious learning.
And yet, operating from that position of profound lack, they raise aggressive, sweeping objections against scholars who have devoted their entire decades long lives to mastering those very disciplines.
It is the ultimate manifestation of not knowing what you do not know.
the arrogance of assuming that a surface level reading equates to a lifetime of deep synthesis.
The master is pointing out an epistemological gap that simply cannot be bridged by a quick conversation.
The gap is too wide.
The vast architecture of insight, the layered context, the historical nuance, and the lived experience possessed by a lifelong scholar are entirely beyond the comprehension of this foolish questioner.
They do not even have.
The tools to understand the answer.
They lack the vocabulary and the conceptual framework.
They're very
Every incomprehension forms the wall of their foolishness.
So if the gap is that vast, what is the instruction for the disciple when confronted by the foolish one?
Is it the same as the jealous one?
It is exactly the same.
Keep away.
Offer no response.
You cannot pour an ocean into a thimble, and if you try, you will only damage the thimble and spill the water.
I like that.
Any attempt to explain the nuances of a lifelong study to someone who fundamentally lacks the capacity to grasp the basics
and them twisting your words, they will walk away more entrenched in their ignorance.
Which brings us to the third category of patient.
We have the jealous, we have the foolish, who is the third?
The third patient is the impatient, simple-minded one.
The impatient, simple-minded one.
This is a person who is not necessarily malicious like the jealous one or aggressively arrogant like the foolish one.
Okay, so a different flavor of obstacle.
Yes.
Because of their restlessness, impatience, and immersion in the material world, they simply cannot absorb the teachings of the spiritually elevated.
They are too distracted.
They rely entirely on their own deficient understanding, and they interpret everything you say only through the filter of their own personal worldly interests.
I think we encounter this constantly.
This is the person who hears a profound spiritual truth.
but immediately tries to map it onto their own limited desires.
Constantly.
They run everything through a filter of how does this help my career or how does this validate my current lifestyle.
Yes, they reduce the transcendent to the transactional.
The transactional.
Their intellect is currently incapable of grasping higher spiritual realities because it is weighed down by base attachments.
So what does the master advise for them?
For this person too, the master says there is
no answer you can force upon them that will elevate them in that moment.
You cannot force the medicine.
He grounds this firmly in a known prophetic command.
We are instructed to speak to people strictly according to the capacity of their minds.
You have to meet them where they actually are, not where you want them to be.
You must respect the limits of their current capacity.
A physician cannot prescribe a heavy, complex regimen to a patient whose body is too weak to handle it.
Would crush them.
If you try to force high-level spiritual realities onto a mind that is entirely consumed by worldly interests, you will end up harming both yourself and the listener.
How does it harm the listener?
The listener will misinterpret the teaching perhaps in ways that are spiritually dangerous to them.
And the teacher will have failed in their basic duty of care.
So we have 3 distinct categories of questioners.
The jealous one, the foolish one, and the impatient simple-minded one.
Right.
And the instruction for all three is essentially to recognize the limits of the medicine.
Do not force a cure where the conditions for healing do not exist.
Exactly.
That leaves only the 4th category.
The 4th patient is the genuine seeker.
The genuine seeker.
This is the individual who is actually seeking the right path of guidance.
They are obedient.
They possess a sharp and intelligent mind capable of deep comprehension, and crucially, they are free from the internal static of anger.
Free from anger.
They are free from following the base desires of the lower self, free from the rot of jealousy, and free from the blinding craving for wealth and fame.
They have done the hard work of clearing the internal debris that usually blocks understanding.
Their slate is clean.
So when they ask a question.
When this person asks a question, or even when they raise a rigorous objection,
from a desire to find fault.
It is not a trap.
It doesn't come from a need to test the teacher or show off to an audience.
It arises from an earnest, desperate search for truth and correct guidance.
And I imagine the master's ruling on how to handle this person.
is entirely different.
It is the exact opposite.
This is the patient who can actually be cured.
The only one.
Therefore, to answer the questions of this genuine seeker is not merely permissible for the disciple.
It is a religiously required obligation.
You have to answer.
You have no right to withhold the medicine from a patient who is ready to receive it.
I deeply appreciate how the master frames the boundaries of teaching here.
The inability to cure the first three patients is not a failure of the teacher's knowledge.
Not at all.
It is simply the reality of the patient's condition.
But when the medicine can work, withholding it becomes a spiritual crime.
Yes, a crime against the seeker.
This entire aside about debate and questioners is really about preserving the purity of knowledge.
It is about not throwing precious insights into the fires of envy or against the walls of ignorance,
but planting them where they can actually take root.
That is a perfect summary.
And understanding that dynamic seamlessly sets up the master's second major admonition.
The second refraining.
Yes.
He tells the disciple to categorically refrain from the reality of preaching and making speeches.
Now, given that the disciple is a scholar, preaching would seem like the natural outlet for his knowledge.
Why this massive prohibition on delivering sermons?
The grounds for this prohibition are brutally simple, and they are entirely focused on integrity.
Integrity.
A preacher cannot possibly lecture others from a soul that he has not first rigorously instructed himself.
Self-instruction is the absolute prerequisite.
You cannot give what you do not possess.
He drives this home by citing a divine warning given to the son of Mary.
What was the warning?
The command was stark.
First admonish your own soul.
Then only if your own soul accepts your counsel and alters its behavior, you may step forward and admonish others.
And if your soul does not accept it?
Otherwise you should have immense shame before your creator.
Have shame before your creator.
That points to the deep hypocrisy of telling a crowd to abstain from a hidden sin that you yourself indulge in when no one is looking.
Exactly.
Or urging them to pursue a virtue.
that you are too lazy to practice in your own home.
It is a spiritual contradiction that slowly destroys the preacher from the inside out.
The gap between public words and private reality becomes a canyon that the soul falls into.
A canyon.
However, the master acknowledges the reality of the disciple's position.
He says that if circumstances arise that absolutely compel the disciple to preach, if the duty falls upon him and cannot be avoided, then there are two massive guards he must establish to protect his soul.
Let us examine these guards closely because
They seem incredibly strict.
Guard 1 deals with the external delivery, what a sermon must not be.
Yes.
The master demands an absolute, uncompromising rejection of the performative pulpit.
No performance.
He tells the disciple to avoid using colorful, entertaining narrations.
Avoid theatrical gestures designed to captivate the eye.
Nothing designed just for engagement.
Exactly.
Do not use secretive, esoteric language that simply makes you sound mystically superior to the common people.
Avoid flowery, embellished speech and do not rely on pleasing poetry to soothe the audience.
He is essentially rejecting every single technique that makes a public speaker popular.
Every single one.
He's stripping away everything that draws a crowd or creates entertainment.
Why?
Because the creator does not love the pretentious and the showy.
The master explains that if a preacher's primary aim is to impress the audience with eloquently crafted language and clever phrasing, then his inner being is already corrupt.
His focus is entirely on himself.
His heart is completely heedless of the genuine remembrance of God.
He is playing a linguistic game while the house is burning down.
And to make the true,
severe purpose of a sermon painfully clear, he introduces an unforgettable analogy.
He asks the disciple to consider a person whose house has been struck by a sudden, violent flood.
A flash flood.
The raging water has reached the very door.
Within seconds, it threatens to engulf the entire structure and drown everyone trapped inside.
It is a moment of absolute paralyzing terror.
In that exact moment of life-ending catastrophe, what does the owner of the house do?
He doesn't craft a beautiful.
He doesn't compose a poem.
He cries out urgently, using the shortest, sharpest warning possible.
L-A-J-Z-R.
Beware, beware, run, the flood water is here.
He just screams for them to get out.
Precisely.
At a moment of imminent disaster, no one in their right mind would describe the rising waters using ornate sentences, secretive vocabulary, or embellished prose.
You wouldn't use decorated poetry to warn someone they're seconds away from drowning.
The master says a sermon must carry this exact same
psychological weight.
The exact gravity of impending disaster.
That completely shifts the purpose of a gathering.
A sermon must be rooted in a genuine, overwhelming fear of one's own reckoning before the creator, and it must convey that exact same unfiltered urgency to the audience.
So it is not a lecture.
A sermon is not an intellectual entertainment.
It is a rescue mission.
A rescue mission.
Its plain, unvarnished purpose is to speak of the severe punishment of the hereafter.
It is designed to bring the audience
face to face with the reality of absolute accountability.
What specifically should they be talking about?
The preacher must describe the awe-inspiring appearance of the Angel of Death.
The terrifying questioning in the grave, the incomprehensible spectacle of accountability on the day of judgment.
The actual stakes.
The precise weighing of deeds, the perilous crossing of the bridge over hell.
He is saying that the existential stakes of human life are far too high for flowery speech.
Way too high.
If you are using poetry to entertain the crowd, you have forgotten that the house is currently flooding.
You are distracting the drowning people with your vocabulary.
That is exactly it.
You are providing them with aesthetic pleasure
when you should be throwing them a lifeline.
That brings us to guard 2.
If guard 1 dictates what the sermon must not be externally, guard 2 is about what the heart must not seek internally.
This addresses the hidden, deeply poisonous motivations that can infect the preacher, even if he uses stark language.
The internal trap.
The master warns that while delivering a sermon, you must aggressively guard your heart against the thought that after you finish,
The people will shout your praises.
The quiet, desperate desire for the crowd's reaction.
The secret hope that the audience will fall into visible ecstasy or tear their clothes in a display of religious fervor.
Or raise a massive clamor in the gathering.
Exactly, declaring to each other what a wonderful, transformative sermon was just given by this uniquely amazing person.
It is the desire to be the focal point of their spiritual experience.
You want them to feel something deeply, but you want to ensure that you are recognized as the one who made them feel it.
Is pure, concentrated ostentation.
It is performing for the creation rather than serving the creator.
And the master is having none of it.
He says that to be pleased by these thoughts or to engineer your sermon to produce these reactions is absolute proof of a catastrophic lack of wisdom.
The pulpit has simply become a stage for the preacher's ego to harvest admiration.
And what happens when a sermon or a community is driven by that kind of ostentation?
What is the outcome?
It becomes a source of complete ruin for both the preacher and the audience.
Both of them.
The master is incredibly forceful in his language here.
He says such a person has become a willing slave to his own degraded lower self.
He is imagining that the sacred pulpit is just a theater to display his rhetorical abilities and harvest the
fame of the world.
And what is the master's ruling on this?
He delivers a strict ruling.
He says that whoever has the authority to remove such a performative preacher from the pulpit, it is obligatory upon them to do so deliberately and firmly.
That is a staggering command.
He is saying it is an obligation to silence them because they are actively distorting the entire purpose of religion.
They are weaponizing the fear of God to build a monument to themselves.
Exactly.
The true intention of a sermon must be purely to summon God's creation away from their obsession with this world and orient them toward the reality of the next.
It is a reorientation.
It is meant to cultivate piety where there is heedlessness.
and to violently loosen their attachment to material things.
If it fails to do that and instead just feeds the preacher's vanity, it is a spiritual disaster that must be stopped.
Which leads us into the third admonition, and this one feels almost violently countercultural, especially for anyone who understands how influence works.
The master commands the disciple to stay entirely away from rulers.
He delivers an unusually sharp categorical rule.
He tells the disciple, you should not greet any king, any person of immense wealth, or any ruler.
Total isolation.
You must stay entirely away from their company and their gatherings.
And he pushes the boundary even further to ensure there is no loophole.
He says, do not so much as lift your eyes to look at them.
Do not even look at them.
Why such total uncompromising isolation from the centers of power?
Because of what proximity does to the soul.
The standard rationalization is always, if I can just get close to the ruler,
just get a seat at the table.
I can influence them for good.
I can provide moral counsel where it is needed most.
The master dismisses that rationalization entirely because he is looking at the unforgiving psychological reality of power dynamics.
What is that reality?
He says that in looking upon rulers and keeping their company lie, many hidden, devastating calamities, if a scholar finds himself in their presence, he will inevitably find himself praising them.
Or at least validating them quietly.
Validating their authority simply by his quiet
in their court.
And the master grounds this severe prohibition in a clear prophetic teaching.
A law is angered when any transgressor or oppressor is praised.
And rulers, simply by the nature of managing vast wealth and coercive power,
frequently tread into transgression.
They do.
They make decisions that crush the weak.
To praise them is to endorse that crushing.
But the psychological logic the master unpacks goes even deeper.
He explains the terrifying sequence of causality.
This is the part that is really striking.
He says that whoever prays for a long life for an oppressor has in effect expressed a desire that sin and oppression be perpetuated upon the earth.
I want to trace the exact steps of that logic because it is incredibly subtle.
If I sit with a ruler and I
begin to enjoy their company, what happens next?
You will inevitably begin to enjoy the favors that come with their company.
The perks.
You will enjoy their wealth, their fine food, the deference you receive from others, and the elevated status they confer upon you simply by allowing you to stand in their court.
It feels good.
It does.
And because human nature is wired to love the source of its comfort, you will naturally begin to love the one providing those favors.
you will feel a genuine, growing affection for the oppressor.
And if I feel affection for them and rely on their favors, I will naturally pray that they live a long time and remain in power so that I can continue to benefit from them.
Precisely.
And in praying for their long life and the continuation of their rule,
You are inherently praying for the prolongation of their oppression over the week.
So your own personal desire for comfort and status has quietly manipulated your heart into actively wishing for the continued suffering of others.
Yes.
The piety of the disciple simply cannot afford that kind of affection.
The slow, invisible infection of proximity to power is almost impossible for the human heart to resist.
That psychological progression is terrifyingly realistic.
You do not set out to support oppression.
You do not wake up deciding to endorse tyranny.
No one does.
You just set out to have a nice dinner at the palace or to secure a little bit of funding on your project.
And before you even realize it, you are making complex theological excuses for a tyrant just to protect your access to the dinner table.
Which brings us seamlessly to the 4th admonition, the final of the four refrainings, refusing gifts from rulers.
It feels like a direct extension of the third point, but he elevates it to a distinct rule.
It is distinct because the trap
of wealth is so specific and so universally blinding.
It is.
The master states the rule clearly.
You should not accept any gifts or wealth from rulers, even if you are absolutely certain that what they're offering comes from entirely lawful sources.
Even if the money is perfectly clean,
Why?
If the wealth wasn't stolen and it isn't forbidden, why can't the scholar take it?
Because taking it corrupts the internal religious path.
It triggers that exact same corruption mechanism we just discussed regarding affection.
The gratitude trap.
Harboring any desire for their possessions and reaching your hand out to take what is theirs causes immediate severe damage to your own path to God.
What is the minimum damage?
The minimum corruption, the very least that will happen to you is that you will begin to love the oppressor who gave you the gift.
Your objectivity will be destroyed by gratitude.
The subtle affection that breeds tolerance for injustice.
You cannot speak truth to power if power is paying your salary.
Yes.
But the master knows his disciple intimately.
He knows the complex architecture of the human mind.
He knows the loopholes we look for.
He knows exactly how a highly educated, deeply religious person will try to rationalize taking the money.
We are infinitely creative when it comes to rationalizing what we want to do anyway.
We are.
The disciple or any listener grappling with this text might immediately think,
What if I take the ruler's money?
Absolutely not for myself, but just to give it to the poor.
I'm strong enough to resist the wealth.
I will take this vast sum and distribute it, bringing much needed comfort to the needy and the marginalized.
It sounds like a deeply noble, entirely selfless intention.
You are acting as a conduit for good.
The master exposes this exact pious sounding thought as a lethal trap.
He says, beware, beware.
It is the bait.
This specific rationalization is the lure.
It is not your own noble idea.
It is bait set directly by Satan, who uses both invisible forces and the whispers of other human beings to plant this justification in your heart.
Uses the idea of charity, the idea of helping the poor, to corrupt the scholar.
That is a brilliant, terrifying manipulation.
Because Aiten understands leverage.
He knows that once the scholar's hand reaches out and takes the gold, the scholar is permanently compromised.
The trap snaps shut.
The scholar effectively becomes an employee of the state, quietly dependent on the ruler's ongoing favor.
The poor, whom the scholar claimed to be helping,
become nothing more than a moral shield used to justify the scholar's own initial compromise.
So the poor are just an excuse for the scholar's lack of discipline.
The master warns that Satan has shed the blood of many and ruined the faith of countless scholars through this very strategy of noble-sounding rationalization.
You justify your proximity to power by claiming you are doing it for the marginalized, but in reality you have just sold your independence.
It is a devastating critique of institutional religious compromise.
For those who want to explore the sheer
of the calamities caused by court money and proximity to power, the master refers the disciple to his larger work.
Where does he point him?
He points him to the master's larger work, the revival of religious knowledge, where he details exactly how wealth dismantles piety.
So we have covered the four things to refuse.
The outward, seemingly respectable public traps,
refusing the ego feed of debate, refusing the theater of preaching without inward transformation, refusing the proximity to rulers, and refusing the corrupting gravity of their wealth.
The 4 refrainings.
This marks a profound shift in the architecture of the letter.
We are transitioning away from the public dangers into the quiet, private disciplines, the things the disciple must actively do.
Of these eight admonitions, there are four things you must do and four things you must not do so that your knowledge does not turn against you on the day of judgment.
The spine returns.
It grounds us again in the reality that knowledge must become conduct.
So we leave the noise of the public square and we enter the silent, private chambers of the heart.
What is the first taking up?
The first taking up is the method of developing an intimate relationship with the law.
And the master provides an auditing mechanism for this relationship that is piercing in its clarity.
What is the mechanism?
He uses the highly relatable analogy of a household servant.
How exactly does he frame it?
He tells the disciple that every single matter, every private thought and every interaction between you and your creator should be conducted in such a way that if your own hired servant were to do the exact
exact same thing for you, would not be saddened.
You would be satisfied.
You would approve of it, commend it, and feel absolutely no anger toward them.
I need to audit my relationship with God by looking at the standard I demand from the people who work for me.
Exactly.
Conversely, whatever behavior you would deeply dislike your servant doing, whether it is negligence, laziness, doing a job halfway, speaking poorly of you behind your back, or ignoring your clear commands,
You must realize that if you fall short in those exact same ways in your own servitude to your Lord, your creator will equally dislike it.
The precision of this metaphor is deeply uncomfortable because it is so observable.
It is undeniable.
If I ask someone to complete a task and they do it resentfully, or they only do it when I'm physically watching them, or they constantly complain about the effort,
I would be entirely dissatisfied with their service.
I would likely fire them.
You would be angry and rightly so because they violated the terms of the agreement.
Yeah.
And the master drives home the profound asymmetry of this analogy to make sure the disciple feels the weight of it.
The asymmetry between the two relationships.
He says to the disciple, you must realize that your servant was not created by you.
merely employed him.
You pay him a temporary wage.
Transactional arrangement.
But you yourself were created, nurtured, sustained, and are
entirely owned by your real creator and Lord.
The power dynamic is infinitely faster.
I didn't breathe life into my employee.
I just paid him.
You are his slave in the fullest, most absolute existential sense.
Therefore, your obligation not to displease your Lord in thought, word, or deed is immeasurably greater than a hired servant's obligation to you.
So the household metaphor asks a brutally simple question.
If you would resent a certain lack of effort or respect in your servant, how can you possibly justify presenting that exact same lack of effort to the one who breathes life into you?
It strips away all of our grand, complex theological excuses and brings faith down to the most basic, observable standard of human fairness.
It makes it impossible to hide.
If it isn't good enough for me, how can I offer to the divine?
Which moves us beautifully to the second taking up.
If the first discipline was inward and vertical, managing the relationship with the creator, this one rotates outward and horizontal.
The second taking up is the method of right relating to the slaves of Allah.
Relating to humanity.
The master instructs that every matter, every transaction, and every judgment between you and other human beings should be conducted in such a way that if they were to do the exact same thing to you, would be pleased and not aggrieved.
This is the golden rule, essentially.
Treat others as you want to be treated.
Yes, but he
elevates it beyond mere social reciprocity.
He grounds it firmly in a sacred hadith, a tradition where the creator speaks.
What does the tradition say?
The tradition says, my slave's faith is never complete until he loves for all human beings what he loves for himself.
Until he loves for all human beings what he loves for himself.
I want to pause on the sheer impossibility of that standard for the human ego.
It is an immense standard.
That isn't just about acting politely.
That requires an internal emotional parody that feels almost superhuman.
It requires the absolute violent dismantling of selfishness.
It is the exact same auditing instrument used in the first discipline, testing your actions by reversing the roles, but now turned outward toward humanity.
Reversing the roles again.
You cannot claim to possess complete faith if you hoard comfort, security, and wealth for yourself while ignoring the suffering of your neighbor.
You just cannot.
You cannot claim faith if you desperately desire mercy and understanding for your own mistakes, but instantly demand harsh, unforgiving justice for the mistakes of others.
Absolute parody of empathy.
If I want success for my children, I must genuinely want success for my competitors' children.
If I want my hidden flaws to be overlooked, I must actively overlook the hidden flaws of the people who annoy me.
The faith is incomplete until that emotional parody exists.
That is the core of it.
This brings us to the third taking up, which focuses on the disciples' primary daily occupation.
The master offers an insistent advice to study and learn, but he frames the pursuit of knowledge within the ultimate deadline.
The ultimate deadline.
He presents a ruthless, terrifying thought experiment.
He tells the disciple, if you truly want to increase your knowledge and study scholarly works, imagine that your lifetime will end in no more than a week.
One week left to live.
Consider carefully in that incredibly compressed time frame.
What kind of knowledge will truly benefit you and devote yourself entirely and exclusively to that?
This thought experiment instantly clears the field of everything trivial.
Immediately.
If I know with absolute certainty that I am going to die next Friday, my reading list changes completely.
The things I thought were so urgent suddenly seem ridiculous.
It evaporates everything superficial.
The master lists the things you would immediately drop from your hands.
What would you drop?
You would never spend those final, precious days studying books on religious debate or linguistics or the intricacies of grammar or poetry.
All of that is gone.
You would instantly recognize that such knowledge offers you absolutely no benefit as you stand on the precipice of eternity about to face the ultimate audit.
So what does the disciple actually study in that final week?
What is the only knowledge worth having when the clock runs out?
The Master says you would devote that entire week to the contemplation of the heart.
You would focus entirely on recognizing the deeply embedded faults within your own self so that you might make amends in whatever brief time remains.
You would be racing against time.
You would rush to purify your heart, to sever your attachments to the world, to adorn your soul with the love of Allah, and to beg for forgiveness.
And the unstated, terrifying implication of the thought experiment
is that we should always be studying as if we only have a week left because none of us actually knows when the week is up.
Exactly.
Mortality is the only true lens for prioritization.
He sharpens this with a second image, doesn't he?
Does, an equally visceral one, he says.
Imagine you were told that the king was going to visit your home next week.
A royal visitation to your personal residence.
How would you spend that week?
You would be consumed with a single overwhelming concern.
that the king's gaze should not fall upon anything unseemly, dirty, or broken.
You would be scrubbing every corner.
You would scrub the floors.
You would clean your body, your clothing, the walls of the house.
You would hide away anything shameful.
You would leave absolutely nothing untended.
You would prepare the physical space to be worthy of the presence of the sovereign.
And the master doesn't even need to spate the application.
He just shows the reality.
He quotes a prophetic saying,
Verily, Allah does not look at your faces or your outward actions, but he looks at your hearts and your intentions.
The heart is the home that the true king is visiting.
The gaze of the supreme ruler rests entirely and exclusively on the heart.
So the master is asking the disciple, if you would spend a week scrubbing your physical house for a mortal king whose power is temporary,
Why does your heart, which is the sole focus of the divine gaze, go uncurified?
That is a staggering contrast.
Why are you obsessively studying grammar and poetry when the house of your heart is filled with the filth of arrogance, envy, and ostentation?
It is a profound, devastating reorientation of priorities.
He is telling the scholar that intellectual mastery of the texts is utterly useless if the heart holding those texts is a ruin.
Utterly useless.
And this brings us to the 4th and final taking up, which shifts
the intellectual and spiritual to the deeply physical and practical.
What is the final discipline?
It is about not stockpiling provision.
This touches on our deepest anxieties.
This is about how much of the material world we clutch onto for a sense of security.
The master sets a definitive ceiling.
He tells the disciple, you should not accumulate more than one year's provision for your family from the goods of this world.
A strict one-year provision limit.
In an environment that constantly tells us we need endless security, generational wealth and decades of reserves just to be safe, a one-year limit sounds terrifyingly precarious.
It feels almost reckless to the modern mind.
It is meant to demand actual trust.
It strips away the illusion that your stockpiled grain is what keeps you alive rather than the sustainer.
But he calibrates this rule carefully, doesn't he?
Does, by looking at the established practice of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
He explains how the Prophet set aside exactly one year's worth of provisions for certain members of his family, offering the prayer, O my Allah, make this provision sufficient for the family of Muhammad.
So the one-year mark is an established prophetic precedent.
It isn't just an arbitrary number the master invented.
It is firmly established, but the master points out a vital psychological nuance in the prophet's action.
The prophet did not set aside provisions for all of his wives uniformly.
He didn't.
No.
He reserved A year's supply only for those whose reliance on God, their inner spiritual certainty was slightly weaker, and genuinely needed that physical, tangible reassurance to feel at peace.
He accommodated their human need for security.
He didn't force a level of asceticism on them that their hearts couldn't handle.
Yes, he met them at their capacity.
But for those among the mothers of the believers whose certainty in Allah was absolute, whose trust was perfect and unshakable, the Prophet did not set aside even a single day's provisions.
Not even a single day's provisions.
They woke up with absolutely nothing stored for tomorrow.
The Master specifically names A Aisha as one of those with perfect reliance.
That level of trust is unimaginable for most of us.
The instruction here is profound because it acknowledges human variance.
It does not flatten everyone to the exact same measure.
Right, the rule isn't flat.
The one-year limit is a ceiling for those who might otherwise hoard wealth indefinitely out of a baseline fear of the future, but it is not a floor.
For those whose hearts are already at complete, undisturbed rest in the care of their creator, stockpiling anything at all is entirely unnecessary.
It is a slight
gliding scale of trust.
The more deeply you trust the unseen provider, the less you feel the desperate need to clutch at the seen provisions.
Exactly.
If your heart knows who is feeding you, don't need to hoard the bread.
Beautifully said.
And with that calibration of trust, the master concludes the four things to take up.
So we have walked the complete 8 contours.
We have.
The spiritual diagnosis has been made.
The rule of life is firmly placed in the disciple's hand.
And the disciple had asked for one more thing in his original letter.
He had asked the master for a permanent daily prayer, a supplication he could recite to carry this discipline and this immense framework into his everyday life.
The master begins his response to this final request by first widening the field of view.
He tells the disciple not to rely on his own invention,
not to craft his own poetic prayers, but to source his prayer life directly from the established canonical traditions.
To go to the source.
He specifically points him to the six most authenticated collections of the prophet's traditions and to the powerful prayers passed down through the family of the prophet.
He is telling him to source his prayer from the deepest, purest wells of the tradition.
rather than relying on his own limited, potentially ego-driven vocabulary.
But within that vast field of tradition, the master carefully selects and hands him one specific, sweeping supplication, instructing him to recite it after every single obligatory prayer.
The structure of the prayer itself is beautiful.
It moves in three distinct blocks, mapping perfectly onto the human experience.
The first block is a profound, expansive request for abundance.
The disciple is taught to stand before his Lord and ask for the absolute fullness and perfection of blessings.
What specifically is he asking for?
He asks for the permanence of both inward and outward purity.
He asks for the all-encompassing breadth of mercy, for physical health, for a lawful increase in sustenance, for happiness, and for lasting ultimate success.
He asks for the best of all deeds and the most beneficial of all knowledge.
It is a sweeping unhesitating request for God to pour out his generosity.
It is completely expansive.
But then, having asked for everything good, the prayer shifts into a second block, which is deeply focused on our own flaws.
Correction.
Having asked for divine abundance, the disciple must face his own brokenness.
He prays.
Reform our deeds.
He begs for a veil to be drawn over his sins and his faults.
He asks God to do him the immense favor of actively correcting all his shortcomings, both those hidden deep inside the heart and those visible on the outside for all to see.
It is an admission of ultimate helplessness.
We cannot fix ourselves without divine intervention.
We need him to correct us.
And we need confidence.
Yes, we need confidence and reliance upon him to endure the pain of that correction.
Which flows directly into the third block, deliverance.
The prayer turns away from the immediate world and toward the ultimate stakes of human existence.
Deliverance from what?
The disciple asks for steadfastness and unwavering perseverance on the path to God.
He begs to be saved from committing any deeds in this world that would become a source of shame, exposure, and humiliation on the terrifying day of judgment.
He asks for the crushing burden of his sins to be lightened.
He asks for liberation from the fire of hell, liberation from crippling debt, and liberation from the oppression of others.
The entire structure of the prayer mirrors the structure of the Master's letter.
Abundance, correction, deliverance.
It is a perfect mirror.
And then at the very climax of this supplication, the Master
distinct divine names.
He names the faces of mercy, invoking the Creator by his ultimate defining attributes.
These names carry the weight of the entire universe.
And there is a.
Profound psychological mechanism behind each one.
Why does the soul need these specific names at the end of this journey?
Because each name answers a specific vulnerability of the human condition we just discussed.
He prays, Ya A Zi E.
He calls upon the victorious, the source of all strength, because the disciple is weak and cannot implement these eight contours alone.
He needs strength.
Yeah, Gaff Erar.
He calls upon the endlessly forgiving, because the disciple knows he will inevitably fail and must constantly return.
The cycle of failure in return.
Yeah, Karim, the generous, whose giving is boundless and not limited by our meager merit.
His generosity overrides our inadequacy.
Yeah, Sattar.
The coverer of false, answering the disciples' deep anxiety about having his hidden hypocrisy exposed on the day of judgment.
The fear of exposure is so real.
Yeah, Halim.
The forbearing and compassionate, pleading for God's patience with our slow, stubborn progress.
We are so stubborn.
Yeah, Jabir.
The compeller and the mender, asking God to forcefully fix and restore the shattered pieces of the heart.
The mender of broken things.
Yeah, Zim.
The magnificent, reminding the soul of the absolute scale of the Creator compared to the petty
tyrants and rulers of this world.
The rulers we were told to avoid.
Exactly, Yakahur.
The subduer begging God to overcome the internal enemies of the ego, jealousy, and ostentation.
Subduing the ego from within.
Yeah, Ramanan, the expansively merciful, whose sweeping grace covers all creation.
All of creation.
Yarahim, the specifically merciful, whose intimate grace tends to the believer.
And the final one.
Most merciful of the merciful, the ultimate cascade of absolute reliance.
Calling upon those specific faces of mercy is the ultimate recognition that we cannot survive our own knowledge without His grace.
Of these eight admonitions, there are four things you must do and four things you must not do so that your knowledge does not turn against you on the day of judgment.
The spine.
One final time, reminding the disciple, even as the echoes of his prayer fade, that the prayer must become physical action.
The master closes the letter with a quiet, definitive signature.
He notes that the book comes to an end only with the help of two ultimate realities.
How does he seal the correspondence?
He invokes them by name, sealing the correspondence.
the absolute sovereign, and al-Wahhabi, the giver of all.
The sovereign who commands the path, and the giver who provides the strength to actually walk it.
The master has answered the letter.
The pages have given the disciple absolutely everything they can give.
The ink is dry.
The rest is up to the disciple's own conduct.
The rest is the soul actually offered.
As we close the master's letter, and as we step back from these eight contours,
The question is no longer what the historical disciple will do, but what we will do.
When you look at the four habits to refuse the adrenaline fueled heat of debate, the ego-driven theater of preaching, the corrupting proximity to power, and the blinding desire for wealth, which of those traps does your soul still secretly cling to the most?
And when you look at the four quiet disciplines to take up auditing yourself as a servant, genuinely loving for others what you love for yourself, studying as if you die next week, and trusting God enough to stop hoarding which of those silent habits does your heart most desperately neglect.